Prof: We begin with
Paradise,
which clearly is different from
the earthly paradise,
two paradises.
We went through the earthly
paradise, this is--anyway,
we begin the third canticle
which is called Paradise.
As you read,
you'll find that Dante uses a
Ptolemaic structure of the
cosmos.
A Ptolemaic structure means
that for him,
as for Ptolemy,
the earth is at the center of
the universe,
unmoved, immobile,
and there are a number of seven
planets that circle around it.
The Moon is thought of as a
planet, Mercury,
then Sun, and then there will
be Mars, Jupiter,
and Saturn.
Beyond that there is this--the
Heaven of a so-called Fixed
Stars and beyond that the
Primum--
the Empyrean,
the heaven of fire,
from which all motion begins,
from which time starts.
That's really where the roots
of time are found and they
stretch out into the finite
world;
so that we really are in the
shadows of the leaves of time,
which means that they are
always falling and being
replaced.
Another thing we have to keep
in mind as you go into Paradise
is that Dante links the--
each of the planets with--I
have said this before,
I know, but it bears repeating,
with one of the liberal arts.
And they're respectively,
the liberal arts are the seven
liberal arts and then there are
two more, since there are nine
heavens.
It begins with grammar in the
planet of the Moon and so you
have to expect that you will
find the language of
grammarians,
grammar--the Moon and grammar
the--a very wide definition of
what grammar can be.
It includes poetry;
it includes history,
it even includes some
rhetorical tropes.
And then the Heaven of Mercury
with dialectics and so you're
expecting to find the language
of dialectics deployed and it's
going to be the--
deployed throughout the canto.
The Heaven of Venus and
rhetoric, that probably is the
least surprising,
eros and rhetoric.
They have an old kinship;
they seem to entail each other.
Then the Heaven of Mars,
the god of war,
which here Dante couples with
music in the persuasion that
music is a harmony made of
discordant parts.
So that there is this kind of
simultaneously a pull and a
strife within the Heaven of
Mars, so that when music.
Then beyond it there's geometry
linked with the temperateness of
Jupiter and beyond it astronomy
of Saturn.
The Heaven of the Fixed Stars
is tied--is linked to ethics.
Whereas, the Heaven of the
Empyrean is really the heaven of
metaphysics as Dante will call
it and you will see the kind of
interesting arguments that Dante
will have,
because in effect he has
changed his mind when writing
the philosophical text known as
the Banquet,
as you know now Il
Convivio,
he writes it in Italian.
He had really claimed that
ethics is the first of--and the
most important of the arts.
It's really the discipline
toward which all the art,
to which all the other arts are
subordinated and toward which
they all point.
When Dante writes the
Paradiso he has changed
his mind about that,
though he also knows that in
many ways you cannot quite
separate ethics,
whatever he means by ethics,
with some theory about how the
world is.
They really are inseparable and
Dante will go on back and forth
in re-configuring the relation
of those two disciplines.
The other thing that I should
mention before we go on,
is that much of the
Paradiso really is going
to come through as a way of-- as
a teaching.
It's already implied that this
should be the thrust of
Paradiso,
by the very idea that there is
the disposition of the arts and
sciences in--
through Paradiso,
which means that the journey
that Dante will have--
this cosmological journey.
It's an interplanetary journey.
He goes from planet to
planet--is already an
educational journey,
that's how he goes through
grammar,
rhetoric, dialectic,
etc., etc., until he reaches
metaphysics or beyond that there
will be theology.
It's literally an educational
journey.
This is already understood,
also it's already carried out
by the focus on the teaching
that Beatrice will deliver.
I have to say a couple of
things, that Dante's teacher in
Paradiso,
and this is an innovative,
very imaginative and highly
unusual move on the part of a
poet,
is not some kind of abstract
matron called Dame Philosophy.
It's not some kind of allegory
of nature.
You do have this kind of
allegorical--
didactic allegories where
nature appears as larger than
disheveled woman,
wounded, because nature has
fallen,
teaching the pilgrim of the
traveler about the secrets of
nature and the wealth of nature.
Here is a personal--his
girlfriend to be sure,
and it's someone who
really--who also replaces all
the other likely candidates for
this teaching which is--
would be Aquinas,
Boethius, Bonaventure,
all figures that he's going to
meet.
It's a mistake to believe,
however,
that, as some great scholars of
Dante have said in the past,
that Paradiso is really
a journey to be Beatrice.
That's what they had said.
That's not the case because
Beatrice will disappear from--
she will still be within view
up to a point in Paradise her
role ends with Canto XXX of
Paradiso and from that
point on,
a mystic by the name of
Bernard, a historical figure,
Bernard of Clairvaux,
will take place.
So this leads me now to a
further clarification.
There may be the tendency in
some of you to view the
Paradiso as some kind of
account of a mystical
experience.
You know what I'm saying,
that Dante sort of goes beyond
his own self,
beyond any idea of rational
understanding of the world,
the surrendering of his own
subjectivity to some insight
into the whole.
This, I don't think that this
is what's happening here.
Dante will preserve his
rationality and his sense of
distinction and separation from
some kind of cosmological and
cosmical hall the very end.
There is a way in which Dante
will deploy the language of the
mystics and I want to give you
some evidence of that,
because I think it opens up an
interesting chapter for your
further readings,
but it's not--this is not to be
read as a kind of transcription
of a mystical experience where
the text then goes on in some
kind of random approximation or
random copying of what the
mystic saw and becomes
ineffable.
Dante uses, occasionally,
toward the end the language of
ineffability but this is--
remains a poetic construction,
an imaginative projection into
what is a journey into the
absolute unknown into a space no
other imagination had really
traveled and it's those--
and have been those who have
traveled there but they never
really took-- came back to tell
us.
Dante will play with that.
His is, to use that language,
a kind of--a way of getting
into that which had been left
inarticulate and silent.
It's really largely a battle
against the--for a poet,
threatening boundaries of
silence.
Something that threatens him
with defeat, he will not be able
to speak.
And from one point of view that
defeat for the Christian would
also be of course a victory but
Dante is suspended between the
two poles.
If I had to define,
and I have already given a kind
of general definition,
what kind of aegis,
under which rubric should we
try to go on reading this part
of the poem,
I really think this is really a
poem about beauty,
in the sense that Dante will
try to understand what the
beauty is.
The beauty is the visibility
of--Plotinus says this,
it's the visibility of being,
he calls it,
being life, the whole of life
becomes visible only because we
have perceptions and images of
it so it's--
I think that Dante's trying to
see that,
to explore what is it that lies
beyond that which we see.
What is this beauty skin deep,
as it were,
because that's really one of
the dangers of focusing on
beauty that it's really the
surface of things,
the appearance of things.
And he will go between
appearances, images,
and the idea that they are
essences lying beyond them.
I really have said more or less
all I had to say in the mode of
an introduction.
I immediately get into Canto I.
Let me just read Canto I a
little bit with--
in some detail,
"The glory,"
that's the way it starts,
"The glory of Him who
moves all things penetrates the
universe and shines in one part
more and in another less."
That's the first tercet,
famous first tercet and I will
read this in Italian so that you
sense how even the rhythm of the
poem completely changes.
The rhythm and even the
syntactical structure of the
poem,
because you may recall and I
say this knowing that you have
already noticed that,
that if you read Canto I of
Inferno or Canto I of
Purgatorio,
the two exordiums of the other
canticles,
you know that the poet is
immediately casting himself into
the role of the agent.
"In the middle of the
journey of my life I found
myself,"
that's really the very start of
Inferno I,
and in Purgatorio too,
"To course over a better
waters the ship--
the boat of my genius now goes
and I will sing,"
you remember?
Not so in Paradise.
There is a way in which,
immediately,
the first tercet,
which has a sort of proemial
value,
seeks to bracket the idea of
the self and the idea of the
subjectivity.
It emphasizes the question
of--God becomes the agent here,
to say it in a very direct--as
directly as he says,
"The glory,"
it's a circumlocution once
again,
but let me read it in Italian,
so that I can give you a sense,
as I said, of the new music
that he has found.
The new sense of the inner
harmony that toward which
language has to strive.
La gloria di colui che tutto
move
per l'universo penetra e
risplende
in una parte più
e meno altrove.
It's rendered very faithfully
by Sinclair.
I don't know the other
translations but probably it
can't deviate from it very much,
and I read it in Italian
because also--
and this is understandable to
the eye,
if not just to the ear for you,
how he's playing with--
in line one,
"The glory of him who all
moves."
So God the mover I'll talk
about it in--later on,
the one who moves all and that
all then becomes one in the next
line, universe.
The all becomes that which is
turned into one,
that's what etymologically--the
universe.
It goes on, "Penetrates
the universe and shines in one
part more and in another
less."
Well the tercet casts God--this
is about God,
as a circumlocution,
it is not--it's really a God
who is visible through God's
effects,
as God appears as kind of cause.
Now then, if you really
understand the effects,
it means there is a causality.
I don't want to get into--too
much into that but you know what
I mean,
that--simple,
you only know the effects,
you know the glory,
we see the glory which is the
light.
Glory, it's a semantic--the
first thing we have to say,
this is a shift,
a change in the history of the
word.
That's what poets do,
that poets invent,
reinvent language;
that's largely what they do.
They change the meaning of
words.
Glory, in the classical time
and all the way down to the
Renaissance and the Romantic
age, glory means fame.
It means, it's the child of
Clio.
It means, it's the power we
have to survive,
not to have a posthumous life
because of whatever noble deeds,
heroes may have achieved.
That's not what it means here.
Glory means light, of course.
It's the light who wants fame,
if you wish,
but this is the light.
Why do we know that?
Because light now is linked to
two verbs of the "glory of
Him who...
all things,"
who moves all things,
penetrates the universe,
and shines.
You see there is a metaphor of
light that is conveyed here.
So the first tercet presents
God in a cosmological role which
is double: one of motion and one
of light, two things.
Dante is combining an
Aristotelian idea of God as the
prime mover, one who imparts
motion to all things.
And in the second image is that
God as the principle of light,
a neo-Platonic idea.
He's fusing together two
contradictory,
apparently contradictory,
traditions: light and motion.
One is talking in terms of
causality and the other one
really--
I'm not going to go much
further than this,
the other one in terms
of--because light does that,
penetrates, shines all over,
according to a principle of
hierarchy: more and less.
There is no uniformity in--with
light, and I'll come back to
this notion in a moment.
One idea casts God as the prime
mover,
according to the tradition of
Aristotelian philosophy,
the other one thinks of God as
in the mode of light or
participation.
They are two different
theological modes.
God participates,
is part of creation,
the natural world is part of
the supernatural world.
There is not just a causality
that begins all things and then
somehow retreats in some sort of
invisible and unknown non-space
of its soul.
The other item in this first
tercet is that of the--that I
want to emphasize is the
principle of hierarchy.
Light shines more and less.
I have been hinting at this,
that this is really a great
problem for Dante in other parts
of the poem.
You remember "to course
over better waters,"
Dante says in Purgatorio
I,
and that implies of course that
there are bad,
good, better,
best--that we are in the
principle of hierarchy.
Differences are very crucial
for Dante because they allow us
to know things,
only through differences,
and also the--
because these differences--and
that's the value of hierarchy.
They are still combined in some
kind of unified structure.
Hierarchy is a structure that
unifies all differences
according to the principle of
degree.
More of this a little bit
later, as we go on.
Then Dante now,
as I said, that he's not a
mystic.
Subjectivity is not erased.
Mystics tend--though they all
claim a unique vision,
they all end up resembling each
other when they talk about the
ineffable.
And Dante introduces now the
subject and he says,
"I was in the heaven that
most receives His light."
That is to say passed in the
Empyrean, which is sort of
spiritual, he as close to God as
he could be, which will also be
as far from God as it can be.
"I was in the heaven that
most receives His light and I
saw things which he that
descends from it has not the
knowledge nor the power to tell
again."
No sooner does Dante introduce
his subjectivity and his way of
knowing out of this intimacy
of--
and closeness to the beatific
vision,
then he has also to cast
himself as a visionary,
has "the knowledge or the
power to tell.
I saw things,"
and you will see how Dante goes
on refining his eyesight,
a little detail that you might
really enjoy is that we do know
that Dante would use lenses--
glasses toward the end of
the--had just been invented.
There are books written about
when were glasses invented,
were they invented in Pisa?
Were they invented in Padua?
There have been wars going on
about this claim,
but Dante uses glasses,
so he really had
difficulty--that's the point--in
seeing.
All of Paradiso is about
the refinement of sight and the
refinement of vision.
How you are going to be able to
attune as it were your eyes to
the objects around you.
Anyway he casts himself now as
a visionary with an internal
vision.
I'm not casting him as a Homer
who is blind,
and therefore he sees
everything with the inner eye,
but he wants to be a visionary
poet,
and "I saw things
which," that is to say one
who sees things as a whole.
That's the difference between
ear,
there are great debates between
the ear and the eye is that the
ear you hear,
and you hear always--only from
one in a linear way.
Things can come from all sides
but you can only catch a thing
at a time.
With the eye you have--the eye
is the organ that gives you the
chance to--the organ of the
contemplatives;
it gives you a chance to see
totalities.
"I saw things which he
that has the sense from it has
now the knowledge or the power
to tell again and then he
explains why.
He explains the status of his
poetic language.
"I saw what is the
relationship between language
and vision?
That's the--if you want to put
it in a very abstract way,
how are the two related?
"For our intellect,
drawing near to its
desire..."
The intellect yearns,
longs for the objects that it
desires.
So there is a desire of the
mind, a desire--
it's not just a desire for the
intellectual,
"desire,
sinks so deep that memory
cannot follow it."
Very simple,
forgetfulness intervenes so
that the--he may have intuition,
and insight into things,
he cannot quite go on
recalling.
"Nevertheless,
so much of the holy kingdom,
as I was able to treasure in my
mind shall now be matter of my
song."
Whatever he's going to tell us
is literally a shadow of things
he manages to remember.
It makes sense that he should
not remember because part--one
of the paradoxes of this poetic
construction is the following,
he has a beatific vision.
How can he retain in his mind
this sight, which is finite,
that which is infinite?
If not through vestiges and if
not through shadows?
How can you--how can my memory
which is a metaphor of time,
by definition,
he remembers certain things,
but how can I go on remembering
and holding that which is
without time,
which is infinite?
So the first paradox of--in the
representation of Paradise.
Let me go on with the next one,
next paragraph now,
Dante turns to god of poets,
to Apollo.
"O good Apollo,
for the last labor make me such
a vessel of thy power."
He casts himself into a passive
mode, a vessel,
one who receives.
It's the language of restraint.
It's a language of holding back.
It's in a sense it's really the
classical commonplace of asking
the muse to breathe through us.
"Sing to me o muse,"
remember?
The Iliad,
and a variant of the same
thing--a variation of the same
thing happens in the
Odyssey.
"For the last labor make
me such a vessel of thy power as
thou requirest for the gift of
thy loved laurel."
What an extraordinary image.
He was remembering the story of
the god who chases Daphne,
the object of his desire,
which he cannot really obtain.
That's the story--you all know
the story in the Metamorphosis.
He can only obtain Daphne,
which means laurel in Greek,
but he only can obtain this
young maiden Daphne in the form
of a metaphor for the laurel
crown.
So it's a sort of journey which
somehow the object of which
becomes--
the possession of the object
becomes dislocated,
not quite what the god himself
wanted,
but this introduces something
else about the Paradiso.
"Thus far,
the one peak of Parnassus has
sufficed."
You may remember this is a
recall of the dream of Parnassus
in Purgatorio that we saw
when Statius and Virgil were
flattered into believing that
what they had dreamt is actually
the simulacrum of the earthly
paradise.
Thus far, the one peak of
Parnassus has sufficed me,
but now I have need of
both," a language of
humility,
"entering on the arena
that remains."
There's a struggle now.
First of all,
he had introduced this image of
himself as a vessel receptive to
the inspiration of Apollo,
now the language of even
violence "on the
arena" where there is
sports,
where battles are fought,
enter into the arena--
now entering "on the arena
that remains"
and now look at this,
"Come into my breast and
breathe there as when thou
drewest Marsyas from the
scabbard of his limbs,"
an echo of the struggle between
the poet and the god.
He does not want to be like
Marsyas because Marsyas,
out of presumption--now you
understand the language of
restraint and withholding--
out of presumption,
Marsyas had tried to outdo
Apollo,
and, of course,
was defeated by Apollo and
flayed by Apollo.
Dante does not want to--what
this is about the fear in the
battle for the description of
Paradise, the fear that he may
be usurping God's role.
The fear that he may be
transgressing and violating that
which is the sovereign claim of
the gods.
So he continues now:
"O power divine,"
so that's one of the images of
fear of blasphemy,
fear of transgression,
and this will continue.
Remember the possibility of
hubris, in other words.
And then it continues,
"O power divine,
if thou grant me so much of thy
self that I may show forth the
shadow of the blessed kingdom
imprinted in my brain,
thou shalt see me come to thy
chosen tree,"
of laurel,
"and crown myself then
with those leaves of which the
theme and thou will make me
worthy.
So seldom, father,
are they gathered for triumph
of Caesar or of poet--
fault and shame of human
wills--that Peneian bow must
beget gladness in the glad
Delphic god when it makes any
long for it.
A great flame follows a little
spark," etc.
And then, "The lamp of the
world"--I'll just give you
this--Dante is approaching,
he's moving.
He thinks he's on earth and he
discovers--I will not go on into
details--he's in the Heaven--of
the Moon.
So he describes here,
this is the image at the bottom
of page 21,
line 65 and following:
"Beatrice stood with her
eyes fixed only on the eternal
wheels,
and on her I fixed mine
withdrawn from above.
At her aspect,
I was changed within as was
Glaucus when he tasted of the
herb that made him one among the
other gods in the sea."
It's a story of--clearly the
pilgrim is moving into another
level of experience and a level
of being,
and he remarks on the
transformation that he is
undergoing.
The emphasis falls--and the
distance between--
the Ovidian account of Glaucus
who believes that he's immortal
and jumps into the water of the
tasting of some herbs,
and Dante himself has indicated
by that little preposition
'within.'
The transformation occurs in
Dante from within himself not in
some literal way outside--on the
outside.
Then he continues,
"The passing beyond the
humanity cannot be set forth in
words;
let the examples suffice,
therefore, for him to whom
grace reserves the
experience."
The experience the pilgrim is
having is unique and
irreducible,
and the poem can only be read
as an example,
as an account of what has
happened to him.
Then he continues,
"If I was only that part
of me which Thou createdst last,
Thou knowest,
Love that rules the heavens,
who with Thy light didst raise
me."
Your notes, your footnotes will
tell you that this is a
reference to the Second Letter
to the Corinthians,
Chapter XII,
by Paul, by St.
Paul, where he also tells the
story of his being rapt to the
third heaven.
We have then two accounts in
Canto I of experiences--one is
that--of encounters with the
divine.
One is that of the profanation
by Marsyas and the other one is
by St.
Paul, who as you recall,
Dante casts as one of the
possible models for him.
He says, when at the beginning
he has to set out on a journey,
he says, "I'm not Aeneas,
I'm not Paul."
Now we see how Paul comes into
play.
Who am I then?
That was the whole thrust of
the poem.
What happens to Paul?
Paul goes to the third heaven
and people have a way of--had a
way in the Middle Ages
especially, so how many heavens
are there?
The third heaven--what is meant
by the third heaven was the
third mode of vision.
There are levels of vision that
they emphasize.
There is a literal level,
the carnal worldly level.
There's an imaginative vision,
and then there is the ecstatic
vision that Paul had.
The thing is,
in the Second Letter to the
Corinthians,
is that Paul went to the third
heaven,
had the vision of God,
the beatific vision,
he returned and could not speak
about it,
because what he saw had to be
kept wrapped in silence.
This is now--Dante is between,
on the one hand Marsyas and
that fear of profanation,
and now Paul.
It is as if he also is
transgressing the teaching of
Paul.
The whole of Paradise is
about limits and the
impossibility of establishing
clear limits.
He will do what Paul himself
could not do.
Paul kept quiet in the belief
that the silence was the proper
language of his sublime
experience.
Dante will go on speaking until
it's possible for him to do
so--until finally he really has
forgotten everything that he has
seen.
You see how he is casting
himself?
His own poetic powers,
his own subjectivity between
two different modalities.
He doesn't want to go as
presumptuously far as Marsyas
did.
He does not want to retreat as
Paul did.
I really think that I should
let you know--;it's a little
digression, before we go into
the second part of the canto.
In Cantos I and II where Dante
is really going to face a
peculiar issue,
the universe I'm in.
Is it a material universe?
That's the thrust of Canto II.
Is this a natural--part of the
natural world or not?
Of course, he goes on talking
about the spots on the Moon,
etc., we'll come to that.
Here in Canto I,
we shall see that he's going to
discuss the arrangement of the
cosmos.
You have to know,
I want you to--I want to share
with you a couple of paragraphs
of a letter that Dante writes to
introduce Paradise.
This is what had happened.
He lives in Ravenna when he is
writing.
He's probably in Ravenna by the
time he writes the earthly
paradise.
As you know,
he makes references to the
Garden of Eden in terms of the
park,
the pinewood,
the wood of pine trees around
the city,
and we do know that he would
live and die in Ravenna.
He decides to send the first
ten cantos of Paradise to the
so-called Cangrande,
the great dog of Verona,
who had been his patron for a
number of years and he
introduces those ten cantos that
he sends with the letter called,
The Letter to Cangrande in
Italian.
It's the--Dante writes--you
know that, this is the tenth
letter of a number of letters
that he writes.
This is the--let me just read
this--it's a kind of glossing.
It explains the genre of the
poem explains what his models
have been, and how it has to be
read.
Look what he says about this
circumlocution here about Paul
the Apostle.
This is from Paragraph 27.
It's not a really long letter
but I couldn't read the whole
thing without putting you all to
sleep.
"The philosopher presents
an argument consonant with the
above in the first book On
Heaven,"
the philosopher meaning
Aristotle,
"where he says that a
heaven has material more
honorable than that of other
heavens,
beneath it to the extent that
it has this more distant than
they from the earth."
The nobility in the
hierarchical structure.
The nobility of matter will
depend on its proximity to the
source of light and life.
"To this might be added
what the Apostle told the
Ephesians concerning Christ,
who ascended above all the
heavens that he might feel all
things.
This is the heaven of the
Lord's pleasures to which
pleasures Ezekiel refers,
in accusing Lucifer,
'thou wast the seal of
resemblance full of wisdom and
perfect and beauty.
Thou wast in the pleasure of
the Paradise of God.'
After having said,
in this circumlocution,
that he was in the part of
Paradise,
he continues," meaning,
meaning I, himself,
"by stating that he saw
things which he in this sense
cannot relate.
And he gives the cause of this
saying that the intellect goes
so deeply into its desire
itself, which is God that the
memory cannot follow.
To understand what this means
it should be noted that in this
life,
the human intellect,
because of the affinity it has,
for the separated intellectual
substance with which it shares
its nature,
reaches such a height of its
exaltation,
when it is exalted,
that upon its return to itself,
having transcended the ordinary
capacity of men,
memory fails.
This idea is implied to us by
the Apostle addressing the
Corinthians,"
the passage I just read,
"where he writes,
"I knew a man,
whether in the body or out of
the body I know not,
God knoweth,
who was caught up to the third
heaven and who heard secret
words who it is not granted to
man--
which it is not granted to man
to author.
See, when the intellect had
passed beyond the bounds of
human capacity,
in its exhaltation,
it could not remember what
happened outside these bounds
and the same idea is implied to
us in Matthew where the three
disciples fell down on their
faces and told nothing about it
afterwards as if they had
forgotten.
And it is written in Ezekiel,
"I saw and I felt upon my
face."
But if these passages don't
satisfy the skeptical,
let them read Richard of St.
Victor and his book on
contemplation,
or Bernard of Clairvaux,
in his book on consideration,
or Augustine,
in his book on the capacity of
the soul,
and they will be no longer
skeptical.
Or if they should bark out
against the possibility of such
exaltation,
because the sinfulness of the
speaker,
they should read Daniel where
they would find that even
Nebuchadnezzar,
by divine permission,
saw something which was a
warning to sinners and then
forgot it.
For he who make the Sun to rise
upon the good and bad,
and reign it upon the just--and
the unjust--
manifests His Glory to all the
living,
no matter how evil they are,
sometimes mercifully,
for the sake of the conversion,
sometimes harshly as a
punishment and to a greater or
less degree according to his
will."
The reason why I want to share
this passage with you is that it
really places with some
clarity--
it casts, it projects a light
of--that makes things clear
about the status of the poem.
The poem invokes a number of
models which are all in the
contemplative philosophical
tradition.
Or again, Dante is not a
student of the prophetic
tradition, but he makes them
agree with the same mode of the
visionary.
You see, that's what the
prophets do, they see in order
to speak.
If you are readers of the
Bible, you probably have heard
and you may be right,
and if you were to believe,
that there really is no
necessary link in the Bible
between vision--
between the mystics,
those who have visions and
those who are prophets.
They are different experiences
of two different states,
not so for Dante.
It may be true in the Bible
that they are two--Dante thinks
that the two will go together.
You have to have vision in
order to speak and that's really
what the--
it helps us understand the
sense of poetry with which Dante
invokes here at the beginning of
Paradiso.
Let me go now,
Dante has to go on--tries to
find out on lines 90 or so--how,
asks the question about what
has been happening to him.
How has he been moving--he
thought he was on Earth and the
earthly paradise,
now he seems to be on another
planet.
Line 95: "If I was freed
from my perplexity,"
Beatrice dismisses some fancies
of his,
"thou makest thyself dull
with false fancies,
so that thou canst not see as
thou wouldst if thou hadst cast
them off.
You are no longer on earth as
you think, but lightening flying
from its own place,
never ran so fast as thou
returnest to thine."
The journey--Dante is traveling
so fast, the speed of light,
to go from the earthly paradise
to the Moon.
"If I was freed from my
perplexity,
by the brief words she smiled
to me,
I was more entangled in a new
one and I said:
'I was content already,
resting from a great wonder,
but now I wonder how I should
be rising above these light
substances."
Two or three things,
one that I should mention to
you and I will never mention
them again,
but Paradiso is
all--unfolds the whole--
the narrative economy with the
pilgrim experiencing
perplexities and doubts,
which Beatrice will clarify and
in turn those responses go on
triggering new doubts.
It's really a question of
doubts and answers in an
unending process of the mind
enlarging itself and always
filled with wonder,
and that's really the language
that I want to start emphasizing
for you here.
How Dante is using this figure
of admiration,
he calls it,
line 97: "I was content...
resting from a great wonder,
now I wonder."
And this--you will see,
it continues throughout the
beginning of Paradise.
What is this wonder?
It is, first of all,
a definition of the aesthetics
of Paradise.
Wonder translates the Latin,
admiratio,
that's the Italian word,
in English, 'admiration,' which
actually is to be understood,
admiratio, the Latin;
English, admiration,
but for the Middle Ages,
it's nothing less than the
sublime.
If you wanted to translate,
the medieval admiratio,
or admiration,
into an equivalent English--
an aesthetic English term would
be the 'sublime.'
The Pseudo-Dyonisius idea of
the sublime, it's not a romantic
idea, it's probably--you are led
to believe it's an old idea.
It's a Greek notion
of--indicating the mind that is
overwhelmed with the spectacle
of things that dwarf the mind.
Things that the mind cannot
quite comprehend,
that's the sublime.
They can be the sublime in
nature, they can be the sublime
in art, they can be other forms
of the sublime.
Dante's mode of Paradise
is indeed--
this is the oscillation of a
mind that is opening up,
full of doubts,
which really now that's where
he becomes subjective,
critical, and then the
experience of the sublime
overwhelming him.
This idea of the sublime now
introduces a picture of the
universe the way Beatrice will
deliver it.
"She, therefore,
after a sigh of pity,"
I love her I must say,
the way she's going to treat
Dante like a child at this
point,
"bent her eyes on me with
a look of a mother,
a look a mother casts on her
delirious child."
Delirious in the etymological
sense.
I don't think that he's really
actually crazy delirious,
or the word English,
the word we use delirium seems
to me--
simply means 'getting off the
furrow.'
Lirum,
in Latin, means the furrow.
Whatever you go off rut,
as it were,
of some--the furrow that you
are tracing then you are
delirious,
you are going off on your own,
in some kind of silly
direction.
"And she began..."
That's the first picture of the
universe.
We are going to find that this
picture is going to be refined
in a number of ways,
but this is what he can
understand now.
"All things,
whatsoever, have order among
themselves--that's the premise
in Dante's cosmos.
I will just add for you,
and she continues,
"And this is the form that
makes the universe resemble
God."
This is--so that the universe
has a likeness to the divinity.
Two things to be said
immediately: the word order,
in case you don't know,
is ordo--means beauty.
It's the idea that it's the
symmetrical arrangement of
proportionate,
full of light and clarity,
structure of all--of the whole:
ordo.
Even the word forma,
one of it means form,
means that there's a shape to
things but it translates the
Latin pulchritudo,
another synonym for beauty.
The picture of the universe
that Dante--
that Beatrice evokes for Dante
is one of beauty,
which in turn,
implies vision,
because beauty is defined as
that which is seen gives me
pleasure.
This is the famous definition
of Aquinas that which is seen
gives pleasure,
that's beauty.
It's a sort of subjective idea
of beauty.
Here of course,
Beatrice thinks of an objective
order of the world.
It's not the fact that I like
it only,
though Aquinas also gives that
explanation of beauty,
that which seen,
pleases, that implies a self,
a taste, a personal taste,
a very rich medieval
understanding of the aesthetic
experience,
but there is also an objective
idea of the whole universe laid
out in order,
shape, clarity.
These are the number,
proportion, clarity;
these are the attributes of
beauty and this cosmological
beauty.
Let me just continue because
this line,
that the universe resembles
God, seems to be such a nice way
of thinking about the universe,
but if you really think about
it, it's really heretical
proposition.
The universe is like God?
What about the evil that there
is in the universe?
Is it the idea that there is a
continuity between God's
transcendence and God's
imminence, what's he saying?
I know that he used to be a
little bit like Marsyas and he
just doesn't like--
he just likes to be a little
better than Paul,
at least he's going to talk.
But now this is really a
strange statement and therefore
has to be clarified and I think
she will.
I talk like this because I have
to explain that I just was
looking at an old,
a great text of--in view of my
class today.
Last night, I was reading a
great text by A.O. Lovejoy,
some of you may know him,
he was a great--
one of the truly great--an
inventor,
if one can speak this,
of the whole idea of the
history of ideas in the United
States,
he used to be a great professor
in the 40s,
50s, and early 60s at Johns
Hopkins and he wrote a great
book,
which I still advise people to
read,
The Great Chain of
Being, because that's really
the idea.
The Great Chain of
Being, it's this--what is
this great chain of being?
It's this virtual metaphor of
the continuity between the world
of unity and the world of
multiplicity and plurality.
It implies that we are
only--that the universe is--this
arrangement, the chain,
an invisible chain.
It's the idea that reappears in
the eighteenth-century English
literature Pope,
for instance,
he uses--I read this in
Lovejoy.
The--but it also implies--it's
a strange idea as it implies
that the value of things,
the values of every entity
depends on the position one
occupies in the various rings of
the chain.
So that if you are an angel
then you're really above human
beings who are made of both--who
are beastly and angelic at the
same time.
We have this kind of
paradoxical quality of being
spiritual and animal at the same
time.
Then we, according to that
idea, though some of you may
doubt it, we are better than
dogs and dogs are better than
stones, and so on.
It's in a kind of hierarchy,
a system of degrees,
and he, Lovejoy,
goes on saying,
well this is really the moment
when Dante has--
is adopting the idea of the
great chain of being,
and this great chain of being
makes him really unorthodox.
I want to tell you that that's
not true because I think we
should read more carefully this
passage.
This is the beginning here,
talking about this resemblance,
how the universe resemble God.
"Here,"
Beatrice continues,
"the higher creatures see
the impress of the Eternal
Excellence which is the end for
which that system itself is
made.
In the order I speak of all
natures have their bent,"
we all have our own specific
gravity.
We're all drawn,
we all are drawn by our
desires.
We go where our desire takes
us, our desires,
and so there's a kind of
natural instinct,
the natural movement in this
way in which a stone,
if you drop it,
falls always to the ground
naturally,
because of its specific gravity
and the fire,
if you light a candle,
the fire will always go up,
instinctively.
All things move according to
their weight,
according to their specific
weight.
It's a spiritual gravity.
Are we like that?
Is that really what Dante's
saying?
He seems--that's what he seems
to be saying,
"according to their
different lots,
nearer to the source and
farther from it;
they move, therefore,
to different ports over the
great sea of being,
each with an instinct given to
it to bear it on:
this bears fire up towards the
Moon," by the way,
this is really the
passage--Dante's rewriting a
passage from Augustine's
Confessions,
"this is the motive force
in mortal creatures,
this binds the earth together
and makes it one.
Not only the creatures that are
without intelligence does this
bow shoot, but those also who
have intellect and love,"
meaning us.
We have intellect and love.
Remember the famous great poem
from--about "women who have
intellect and love"?
Now we all have it,
she says, "The providence
that regulates all this makes
forever quiet with its light,
the heaven within which turns
that of the greatest
speed," on top,
the Primo Mobile,
"and thither now as to a
place appointed the power of
that bowstring is bearing us
which aims at a joyous
mark."
"It is true,"
now, that's the correction to
Lovejoy's interpretation,
"it is true that,
as a shape often does not
accord with the art's intention
because the material is deaf and
unresponsive,
so sometimes the creature,
having the power,
thus impelled,
to turn aside another way,
deviates from this course,
and, as fire may be seen to
fall from a cloud,"
lightening for instance,
light does not go always up,
light can go also down,
"and as fire may be seen
to fall from a cloud,
so the primal impulse,
diverted by false pleasure,
is turned to the earth."
In other words,
within the description of the
order of the cosmos,
Beatrice goes on to say that
human beings are the odd
figures,
that we, somehow,
have the power to deviate from
this pattern of order.
That we can undo.
We have this paradoxical
freedom that makes us either
stay within a particular idea of
what God may have meant or
really for us,
or really breach that
particular order.
Human beings are the absurd
elements in this ordered
portrait of the universe.
That is the whole statement of
freedom;
so that Dante is removing from
a deterministic,
that's what would make it into
a heretical text,
a deterministic idea of what
the cosmos then.
"Then she turned her face
again to the sky."
Let me go--I'll go a little bit
quickly on Canto II and so--but
I will need a few minutes.
Canto II, Dante now is on this
fear of the Moon,
if you know that,
and there will be a discussion
on the spots.
There's this whole medieval
legend: if you look at the Moon,
a full Moon you see the dark
spots and the legend was that
Cain--
the medieval legend--that Cain
riding away from the knowledge
of the murder of his brother had
actually,
with the help of God,
God had removed him from the
earth and had taken refuge
there,
and whatever we see there is
just the imprint of Cain.
Dante dismisses this legend and
goes on talking about science.
She, Beatrice,
will have a scientific
discourse, and the question is:
is this a natural cosmos or
not?
Do we see shades on the Moon
simply because there's a density
or not a rarity of matter?
Or is it because,
therefore, light has a way of
going through this matter of the
Moon?
According to the principle,
more or less,
the rarity and density?
Or is it because there's a
different way in which light is
distributed?
The solution Dante gives,
or Beatrice will give,
is the second one.
We see the shadows on the Moon
simply because there is a
different source of light.
In other words,
the natural cosmos has to be
understood in terms of its
metaphysics.
The physics has only--that can
only be understood in terms of
metaphysics,
but what I want to stress to
you is that the natural and the
supernatural are always seen by
Dante as holding hands together.
They are not two separate
worlds.
dimensions.
They are two different ways of
looking at the same thing.
Now let's see how he introduces
the canto, which I think is
important for a number of
reasons.
Canto II: "O you who in a
little bark,"
the language of humility is
suspect at this point,
because we know that the
sublime is the mode,
is the trope that he will use,
"O you who in a little
bark, you,"
he's addressing us;
he's beginning to address
readers, "eager to listen,
have followed behind my ship,
that singing makes her way,
turn back to see your shores
again;
do not put forth on the deep,
for, perhaps losing me,
you would be left bewildered.
The waters I take were never
sailed before."
That's--it gives poignancy to
the little bark.
It's a little bark that is
doing something,
so mighty;
I'm doing such a magnificent,
extraordinary adventure.
"The waters I take were
never sailed before.
Minerva breathes,
Apollo pilots me,
and the nine Muses show me the
Bears."
And then, a restriction of the
agents that he has been
addressing: "You other
few," a kind of reductive
apostrophe,
the very few here.
It's the crème de la
crème,
he would say of you guys.
A very few who really know and
are interested in the mysteries
in the most esoteric,
arcane sciences that he's going
to put out here.
"You are the few that
reached out early,"
the language actually says,
"turn your neck."
This is really a poor
translation.
I don't know what other
translators say.
"You are the few who turn
your neck,"
because it's the whole idea,
another form of presumption.
You may have heard,
you may recall,
in the Bible about the stiff
neck.
Of course, the neck is always
the emblem of conversion when
you want to--
for Plato, you reach a
conversion you really turn the
neck,
that's all you do.
Not for Dante,
Dante you can turn upside down,
but in Plato,
you turn the neck and you know
where the source of light is.
The biblical counter to that is
there may be the stiff neck,
those who do not--who lack
humility.
Behind this metaphor,
there is the whole idea that
what makes a human being--
that what confers dignity to a
human being,
is the power that we,
among all animals have,
to look up at the sky and see
and look at the stars and
therefore wonder.
All other animals are always
looking down.
We are alone.
Of course, there are other
people who believe that what
makes human beings--particular
dignity to human beings--is
something else.
Of all of them,
as those who said,
that we speak of course,
but of all of them,
the one I really like is that
we are capable of laughing.
That's the explanation:
it's an Aristotelian idea,
but it's explanation of comedy.
Here, that's the allusion
though, you are--the few who
could be also implying,
like me, do not be too arrogant
about this.
"..
.who reached out early for
angels' bread,"
knowledge,
for knowledge,
"by which man here lived
but never come from it
satisfied,
you may indeed put forth your
vessel on the salt depths,
holding my furrow before the
water returns smooth again.
Those glorious ones who cross
the sea to Colchis were not
amazed,"
once again the language of
admiration, the language is
sublime;
I'll come to this in a moment,
"as you shall be when they
saw Jason turned
ploughman."
Well, the metaphor of the
journey by water,
to describe now an aerial
journey, so an anti--
Dante is clearly thinking of
that metaphoric compression that
we saw in Ulysses.
You remember the sailing that
became a mad flight,
now here it's the flight that
becomes a sailing.
The notion that he is guiding
us, so the sense of his
responsibility is turning us
back, unlike Ulysses;
we dispose of that mythic
resonance very quickly.
What he's really saying is that
the journey we're undertaking,
which is the reading of this
book, can become extraordinarily
dangerous.
The reason it's dangerous is
because he is traveling over
water that leaves no wake behind
it.
This is the--what I would call
the danger of the seafaring.
In seafaring,
you have no pre-established
routes.
There is no way,
no road, no path that can be
there fixed and you can find,
so he's inviting us to keep
very close to him,
but we might be losing him at
the same time.
The journey by water is not
exactly like the journey by
land, because there are no
pre-established directions
marked for us.
Then finally,
this allusion to Jason;
so he's not like--Ulysses is
like the hero of the Argonauts,
who has gone looking for the
golden fleece.
And it's an image that he
appears at the end of
Paradiso XXXIII,
where Dante has the god Neptune
from the depth wondering at the
extraordinary power of the human
imagination, the human will.
They wonder at the heroics of
Jason.
Neptune is without--he can't
quite believe what he sees.
It's clearly an allusion for
what Dante himself is going to
do, in seeing God face to face,
and then returning to the
earth.
What I want to emphasize,
and here really I will stop and
give you a chance to ask me some
questions, the--is that we
probably never read--
I think we skipped Canto XVIII
of Inferno.
I think we did,
I don't think that I asked you
to read it, and I don't presume
that you would go and read what
I don't ask you to read.
You never really did,
but in Canto XVIII,
Dante--if you go and read Canto
XVIII of Inferno,
you will find Jason punished
among the flatters and the
seducers,
because he is famous for
seducing Hypsiphyle and
abandoning her.
It's a version of what happened
to Theseus and Medea,
it's one of the great fixations
of Greek--
one of the great situations
of--repeated situations of a
Greek tragedy.
An interesting thing is that
Dante now is distinguishing
between the ethical judgment of
Jason,
who is behind in Inferno
XVIII,
and the imaginative aesthetic
value of the adventure itself.
Now, is he saying therefore,
that the good and the beautiful
are really two distinct things?
He's warning us about that and
that's where I want to pick up
the conversation next time when
we are going to be talking about
the value of images and the
ethics of images.
Let me finish here now and see
if there are some questions
which I will try to answer.
Please.
Student:
Dante has--turning their minds
to a bread of angels and then he
talks about the image of water
and all images and symbols that
come in.
It seems a little shaky to me
in talking about
>,
is that you're turning your
mind to bread,
it's very strange thinking.
I was just wondering if you
could talk about that symbolism
or significance of that,
of turning your mind to bread.
Prof: The question is
about explaining the image of
bread in the beginning of Canto
II of Paradise,
where Dante says,
addressing the readers,
that they are turning their
neck too early to the bread of
angels."
I have a question for you;
in what way do you find it
strange?
Student:
I just mean--well I have "eyes"
instead of "turning your neck,
but just talking about the
intellect with the bread...
Prof: Okay,
all right.
The--well the bread of angels,
so I would see the bread of
angels,
and the bread of angels is
knowledge,
so I think that the
implied--the transference,
the metaphorical reading by
Mandelbaum is accurate.
I wish it were more literal,
but just as I think that--
my own translation of
course--Sinclair also,
it's one of the few times that
he deviates from the literal
burden,
because the literal burden of
the metaphor has a number of
resonances which I think are
valuable,
like exactly the stiff neck,
the turning of the neck.
In the context like
Paradise,
where Dante starts out by
clearly locating himself within
some contradictory
possibilities:
the possibility of a
transgression or the possibility
of trespassing,
in the case of Paul.
So where exactly is he?
That image is his--by the image
of the turning of the neck early
for the bread of angels is
also--
reverberates with anxieties
that he has about his own
adventure and his own
enterprise.
That's--I don't know if this
answers your perplexity but--
Student:
So the bread of angels is
really knowledge and then...
Prof: Knowledge,
the bread of angels is
knowledge.
Yeah, that which--the
idea--it's the idea that you
find in the Banquet,
that why do philosophers--well
I'm sure that it's literally
true that there is nothing
better for a great philosophical
conversation than a glass of
wine, and you sit around and you
talk, but it clearly is--it's
the food of the mind,
the food of knowledge,
the taste of knowledge,
etc., all those metaphors.
Student:
Also can you just kind of
>?
Prof: Yes.
Since--that's very good,
that's very good,
because I think--can that be
also grace?
Yes, that's very good,
because we are here in the
world of Paradise and I know
that I'm giving a sort of
philosophical emphasis,
but there is also the--with
Paul, there is also the
theological--we are dealing with
the poetic, more than the
philosophical--the poetic and
the theological to that.
Absolutely, very good,
thank you.
Other questions?
Please.
Student:
In the beginning of Canto I
when he describes how God sheds
more or less più
e meno light on different
parts,
the phrase più
e meno is also used in
Purgatory to describe
different aesthetic
perspectives,
is Dante trying to bring that
in here or is he just talking
about the hierarchy of who God
chooses to shed light on?
Prof: Well good--
the question is in line 3 of
Paradiso I,
Dante uses a phrase,
"more and less,"
talk about the light that
shines on creation according to
the principle of more or less.
Then the concern is that Dante
uses this phrase quite often in
Canto X of Purgatory,
where, in the context of art,
there is that phrase about--
I call it, approximation.
Is Dante joining the two?
Does he want us to put the two
things together?
Let me answer that.
Far be it for me ever to say,
no Dante, does not want us to
do that.
The whole reading,
if there is a principle to the
way I read,
is that the more echoes you can
find the better,
I think, that we serve--the
better we understand the poem
and we reserve--
I take it to be the intention
of the poet.
I had never really conjoined
the two in my own mind for one
simple reason,
because here I think
it's--Dante's asserting the
principle of hierarchy.
I think that in
Purgatorio Dante is doing
something completely different
since the context there is
pride,
he's really reversing all forms
of--
what is the measure of the
human beings?
How do we measure human beings?
I could say that this is
actually a problem that was
here.
Every time you have a hierarchy
I'm really placing myself in
between an order,
a rank of different values,
and so I can say that that is
also happening in Canto I.
Frankly, the context will not
allow me to go too much beyond
this.
Yeah, there is a way in which
every time I talk of hierarchy
I'm talking about a rank
ordering,
and therefore,
the sense of my place it's a
little bit removed from the
concerns here of--
it's there but not the most
compelling argument for me.
You may prove me wrong,
of course, then I would say
this issue appears.
We join things together;
let's try to keep also each
entity in its own specificity,
so that we really understand
that the--
how far his thinking can go
with the representation of a
scene-- then another.
I like that, good.
I like the fact that you
joined, you combined.
Yes?
Student:  I had a
question, who is this audience?
Homer, Virgil and later
Shakespeare, we know that they
are writing or speaking with a
wide range of people
>.
But now when we read him in
Paradise,
I'm so aware of how much one
would need to know about
philosophy and theology and
poetics before you appreciate
what he did.
Prof: That's--the
question is who on earth could
Dante's audience be?
We know who the audience of
Homer, Virgil can be--or is,
but what about the audience,
whether someone has to know
philosophy, theology,
and so on.
My answer is you're right,
that we do know roughly about
Homer,
because after all,
there are--there is always the
Modicus in the Odyssey
who is singing to the audience
at court until Ulysses appears
and rhapsodes and Homer is one
of the rhapsodes,
or maybe the one who stitches
together the voices of the
rhapsodes.
That gives us a miniature
account of an audience.
With Dante it's a little bit
more difficult to understand.
It's, I think,
I can tell you now contemporary
poets think that Dante's poem,
especially Inferno,
ought to be read in the streets
like raps odes going on the
ancient Greece,
they would go from one fair,
one marketplace,
and the day of the market to
another,
and gather people together,
the feast days of the
community,
but I can be a little bit more
romantic.
I think it's true,
but that Dante probably did
read some of his cantos when he
was in Ravenna or Verona to
the--
in the evening gathering,
the circles of courtiers,
but I don't think of Dante as a
courtier.
He doesn't seem to have the
values.
He has aristocratic values of
the mind of course,
but he doesn't seem to share
the social problems of the
court.
I can think of some aspects of
Shakespeare being the poet of
the court.
The poet who would be read by
the queen and he wants--he wants
the queen to read his text,
or the theatre,
we know about the theatre.
A part of Paradiso was
not known at all to some
people--
the first ten cantos were sent
to the patron who probably gave
what today we would call a
grant,
you apply for a grant.
He would give him a gift for
the great, extraordinary
dedication, and that's what
patrons would--the role they
would play.
I think that Dante--and this is
going to be very romantic--
à la Benjamin now--I
think that Dante writes this
kind of poetry at the end for
God.
I don't think that he could
care.
I don't think he has an
empirical audience in mind.
He really means the few.
I don't think it's a rhetorical
strategy at the end:
you few who are going to read
that.
And it's too much written--it's
written too much in the mode of
a quest for God.
A prayer, actually it's a
moment at one point where
language bends into a prayer
and--
with a language of a longing
that goes with prayer,
that I really think it's meant
for God.
I mean it in a very serious
way, and it ends with a prayer:
the great Canto XXXIII is an
extraordinary prayer.
That's my answer.
I'm sure that the--I have a
dear friend who wants to make a
movie about reading Dante in the
streets.
That's fine,
but I'm not sure that that's
what Dante thought.
I mean I'm really not sure
about that.
Great question,
thank you, we'll see you next
time.